the fourth episode of Star Trek the card
titled absolute candor finally sees the
former captain take to the stars
building up his ragtag crew as he
searches for answers about data's twin
daughters from notable historical
figures - nods to previous Star Trek
episodes here are the Easter eggs you
missed prior to the synthetic attack on
Mars 14 years earlier the card was
visiting an order of Romulan assassin
nuns called the coop millet on the
planet Vashti the coop millet are also
caring for a young boy named Elmer a
refugee Picard entrusted to the order
until a more suitable home can be found
for him despite the cards notorious
distaste for children he has a soft spot
for Elmer and brings the boy a copy of
Alexander Dumas The Three Musketeers
the card reads the book aloud to Elle
mark and the two of them
enthusiastically enact some of its more
energetic fencing scenes before Picard
receives the tragic news about Mars
while the Three Musketeers is a popular
tale that has referenced numerous times
in Star Trek history the book plays a
significant role in the next generation
episode hollow pursuits in which a crew
member of the Enterprise creates a
holodeck program in which Picard data
and Geordi play The Three Musketeers
with Riker joining later on as a
diminutive dark tangent in hollow
pursuits the musketeer version of Picard
challenges the real-life Riker to a duel
but when Riker refuses saying he has no
sword and doesn't want to fight the
virtual Picard honson do I detect a
streak of yellow along the Goodfellows
back later an absolute candor Picard
will be challenged to a duel throw down
his sword and refuse to fight early on
an absolute candor dr. agnes jarate
wanders onto the bridge desperate for
some conversation to take her mind off
the boredom and monotony of space travel
when Rios seems reluctant to talk jarate
runs through a list of the things she's
already done to occupy her time
complaining that she was gonna watch a
hollow but all he has on board is
Klingon opera well we're definitely
curious what the story is behind Rios's
Klingon opera collection the
unpleasantness of Klingon opera is a
long-running joke in Star Trek
characters from multiple Star Trek
@array
have repeatedly likened listening to
Klingon opera as a form of torture so
here you were ready to have a nice night
watching the CalNet match and you wind
up spending an agonizing evening
listening to Klingon opera
however on both next-generation in deep
space 9 Worf had a great love for
Klingon opera and prided himself on his
extensive Klingon opera collection and
you're afraid that I might lose your
precious operas
yes Worf was even known to occasionally
break out in song himself if he thought
no one was listening Rios's Klingon
opera hollows might indicate that he and
Worf share a similar taste in music or
possibly that sometime before Rios's
crew consisted entirely of holographic
versions of himself the la serena may
have been home to yet another Klingon
music aficionado
when narak asks Shoji how she speaks
such excellent Romulan she says she
learned it from a friend of her father
who was a professor Marik observes that
she must have learned it prior to May of
2396 when her records say that she
shipped out to the beta quadrant aboard
the Ellison most of the ships mentioned
in Star Trek have some sort of deeper
significance and the Ellison is no
exception
the ship is likely named for Harlan
Ellison an influential and prolific
writer who passed away in 2018 one of
Alison's best-known works was the Star
Trek episode the city on the edge of
forever
which is widely considered one of the
original series finest episodes
although Ellison famously insisted that
the episode that aired was drastically
different than the one he'd written and
that he did not approve of the changes I
felt that they had mucked it up badly
and it took I think six or seven years
before Gene Roddenberry even and I even
spoke to each other again after the show
in the episode the koi accidentally
travels back in time to 1930s New York
and inadvertently alters history and
Kirk and Spock then follow him in order
to restore the timeline Ellison won
several awards for his writing on the
episode including a Hugo Award and the
city on the edge of forever is still
cited as one of the best Star Trek
episodes of all time when Picard beams
down to the Romulan relocation
settlement on the plan
Vashti and absolute candor he's
unprepared for the frosty welcome he
receives from its inhabitants one man
confronts Picard saying he recalled when
Picard came to Romulus with great big
Wallenberg class transports to help
relocate the Romulan people to safety
Wallenberg class transports are a new
type of ship in the Star Trek universe
and are likely named for Raoul
Wallenberg a Swedish diplomat credited
with saving tens of thousands of Jewish
people and Nazi occupied Hungary during
World War two it's an apt name for
transports designed to carry people to
safety in the face of extinction
although also a tragic one given the
Federation's abandoning of their rescue
efforts shortly thereafter Wallenberg
story was turned into the television
film Wallenberg a hero story in 1985
which was overseen by Rick Berman who
served as executive producer for
numerous Star Trek series and films
including the next generation Deep Space
nine Voyager and Enterprise in absolute
candor the specific Wallenberg class
ship that the former Romulan senator
says he boarded during the evacuation of
Romulus was named the nightingale of
course this ship is an obvious reference
to Florence Nightingale the 19th century
woman who is commonly credited as being
the founder of modern nursing
Nightingale was also the name of an
episode of Star Trek Voyager in which
ensign Harry Kim takes command of a
kraler medical transport which he
renames the nightingale
nightingale
the name of someone from my home world
she was famous for treating wounded
soldiers on the battlefield Kim believes
he is helping the kraler transport
vaccines to their home world but
eventually finds out that their actual
mission is to transport a group of
kraler scientists and their prototype of
a cloaking device to the planet and
violation of the prime directive in
absolute candor the Romulans are angry
at the card believing that he willfully
deceived and took advantage of the
Romulan people during a time when they
were most vulnerable while in the
nightingale episode of Voyager it is kim
representing the federation who was
deceived check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Luke
reveals about star tracker coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]